believe believe believe believe believe
believe believe so much of success is
seeing yourself as victorious you have
to see yourself you have to really
believe in yourself and sometimes it's
hard you know you've had failures you've
had weaknesses you've had other things
you have to see yourself as a one-man
band don't rely too much on other people
because they'll let you down you have to
see yourself as victorious and to be a
winner you have to think like a winner
if you don't think like a winner it's
just never going to happen
anything and everything can be done if
you can visualize it and if you believe
in yourself it was the same thing again
when I ran for governor you can imagine
when I went on at the night show and I
announced that I'm gonna run for
governor of the great state of
California people came to me afterwards
and says you're crazy you don't announce
something like this under tonight's show
you have an official press conference at
the State Capitol plus you don't start
with governorship you go start first
with mayor or with state senator and I
said I don't want to be senator I don't
want to be mayor I want to be governor
don't you understand that well the rest
is history I won in 2003 and they won
also in 2006 let me tell you you're
going to find the naysayers in every
turn that you make don't listen
just visualize your goal know exactly
where you want to go trust yourself
get out there and Brooke like hell and
break some of the rules and never ever
be afraid of failure you know I thought
I was ready in 97 right and I didn't
have a major record company marketing
promote my project until 2003 all right
you know so for that time period I had
to be run on my own energy you know I
had to convince myself that uh I'm gonna
make it you know regardless to how
people felt at that time and but what it
does is it makes you feel like what made
me feel like
there's going to be points to people
gonna mistake my confidence for
arrogance because I've had to they don't
understand the process I would do and
how much I had to believe in myself in
order to make these things happen I kind
of I felt you can will yourself into a
good space things are meant to happen
well and you believe in yourself enough
you can help yourself learn you can
inspire yourself in different ways where
you can actually discipline yourself you
know to the point that you can become
good enough like from 97 like when I
started writing it was full-time like
every day I was writing music because I
had no choice if I was gonna stop
hustling then how was I gonna provide or
create continue the lifestyle that I
created for my son's mom my son and
myself I'm not going to sit inside of a
corporation for 20 years the time is now
the time is now to express and for
people to believe in themselves the time
is now for it to be okay to be great
people in this world shun people for
being great for being a bright color for
standing out but the time is now to be
okay to be the greatest you total
believer yeah I believe in manifestation
I believe in you know putting a rocket
of desire out into the universe and and
you get it when you believe it you get
it when you believe you have it and
that's the key is like people still they
sit around going when's it going to come
winds are going to come when's it going
to come when's it going to come and
that's the wrong way you're your face in
the wrong way you're facing away from it
you have to go it's here it's here it's
here whatever the truth is your
perception on how you see that truth
outweighs at 10 to 1 so it's a
motivation and why you're doing it you
know it's in a journey of getting in
shape it's a long long run right but
what the person who's standing at the
end with their hand raised isn't the
person with all the genetics it isn't
the person of the most potential it's a
person that has the greatest
perseverance it's always willing to get
out the difference between a champion
and a loser is that the you know they
both fail as the loser allows the
failure to stand for
with a champion even though he gets
knocked on his ass fahncy toes forward -
to stand back up reface that endeavor
until it becomes his favor till he wins
that's the difference champions get back
up and do it again and a difference
between someone less successful here or
some of the spectator here is that a
person is successful you know they
believe in themselves so much and their
belief overrides any crowds disbelieve
originally when I brought the script to
them they were fairly enthusiastic about
it the one thing they were not
enthusiastic about was me playing the
part and I really can't blame him at the
time Ryan O'Neal I was a candidate Burt
Reynolds Robert Redford Jimmy Caan and
they all were at the top of their game
so I could see it but there was
something inside of me that that you
know this opportunity is never going to
come around and I really wasn't used to
money and I had no idea of what I would
be missing but the temptation started to
come forward first it was 25 grands and
a hundred thousand dollars of my I never
heard of a hundred thousand cuz I had
like a hundred sixty dollars in the bank
and like I said I had to sell my dog and
things were not looking very very good
my $40 car had just blown up so I was
taking a bus to work and was still it
didn't matter I wanted to stick with it
then went up to 150,000 or 75,000 went
up to 250,000 now my head was starting
to spin and it went up to three hundred
thirty thousand and probably I heard up
to three hundred sixty thousand and I
thought alright you know you've really
managed poverty very well you've got
this down to a science you really don't
need much to live on I had like sort of
figured it out so I was not in any way I
used to to the good life song you know
what if I know in the back of my mind if
I sell the script and it does very very
well I'm gonna jump off a building if
I'm not it there's no doubt about I'm
gonna leap in front of a train I'm gonna
be very very upset so this is one of
those things where you just roll the
dice and you fly by the proverbial seat
of your pants I I got a try it I got a
just
to it I may be totally wrong and I'm
gonna be taking a lot of people down
with me but I just believe in it once
again there's no blueprint on how to
beat me I can crack any DaVinci Code
when I'm in that ring I'm the best right
now do you believe you're the best in
the world
I feel I'm the best ever I broke
everybody record to record I haven't
broke it's not bragging about it the
proof is in the pudding men like women
line numbers don't lie doesn't matter
who it it doesn't matter the Sugar Ray
Leonard Sugar Ray Robinson Muhammad Ali
doesn't matter I respect him I take my
hat off to them but you think I gave
this sport my whole life to say there's
another fighter that's better than me
absolutely not you know I mean there's
so many mistakes salespeople make I
think you need to get down to like the
main ones but you're not selling the
solution I mean even before that though
I would say carenage is the biggest
mistake people are not excited they're
not alive they're not they're not
showing interests in the cycle and they
lose interest I was in Barcelona
recently and I was looking at a watch
and the cycle didn't didn't close I
could have bought the watch I was
qualified to buy the watch I'm the one
that walked myself in the shop on my
vacation to look at the watch I knew
exactly the watch I was looking for and
when I left my wife said what could he
had done to close the sale I said well
he could have kept life in the cycle he
could have kept the cycle open so what I
mean by that is look if you're not
interested if you don't believe the
cycle can be closed it will not close so
the number one mistake I think
salespeople managers and the store makes
is they assume a clothes can't be had
that day I go into every cycle every
sales cycle with every prospect every
phone call every no matter how complex
the sale is or how simple it is with the
belief that I can sell that product that
day this time now yeah I think was like
really young and said I want to be a cop
or something but I kind of always knew
that I wanted to make games and I said
so in school to my like career counselor
thing and she said well that's probably
not going to happen
yeah thank you guys so much for watching
this is a new series that I'm testing
out that I love your feedback on by
taking common lessons across the famous
entrepreneurs and compiling them into a
mash-up and having a different theme
each time so let me know what you think
of the video I love your feedback
leaving the comments below
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon